we begin the nine o'clock hour with some
breaking news the cricketer joe root has
announced that he is stepping down as
england men's test captain he's led the
side since 2017 at jackie belcher with
me in the studio yeah he's led the side
since 2017. of late he's he's not led
them to much success no and what is
bizarre with this situation is he
himself has been very successful he's
the most incredible batsman you know the
fact that he um he ended 2021 which was
a terrible year for england cricket uh
with
1708 test runs which is the third most
in history so he is basically pulling
his weight as a batsman over and above
over and above doesn't mean you're a
great captain though he is not getting
the best out of the rest of the team now
if is that down to him is that down to
his tactics is it just down to the fact
that the others aren't in the same
league as he is i mean he started you
know five years ago he started off
really well as captain and it was a very
successful run for england but of late
one win in 17 tests you know they
actually equaled england
bangladesh's record of nine test defeats
in a year in 2021 and i think there's a
whole this is a whole crisis which has
been building for a very long time
england very good at the short forms of
cricket increasingly good at the short
forms of cricket and the test side seems
to have been left to sort of just you
know bumble along and achieve whatever
they could and of late as you said
they've not been achieving anything
there was you know the most recent
defeat in the west indies they were
absolutely thrashed and crushed
humiliatingly uh by australia in the
ashes you know they were two one down to
india when that was postponed because of
kovid you know they lost it home to new
zealand i mean you can just keep going
back and back and back and it just you
know the record doesn't get any better
for a very very very long time back so
i guess he thought you know he there
must be someone better for the job but
who that well that's that was going to
be my question
is there an obvious replacement for root
no there isn't i mean you can say ben
stokes probably is the most obvious
because you know he's very senior
he himself is obviously very talented
he's a match winner we know all that
about ben stokes um can you think of
anybody else i mean it was you know when
alice you're asking the wrong man to be
honest with you jackie the cook was
standing down it was it was pretty
obvious you know it was joe wrote you
know he's the first name on your team
sheet so it was going to be him and his
you know his his cricket now is
exceptional it always has been but um
i i just don't think you know apart from
ben stokes who would you pick their top
order has been abysmal nobody can quite
make that step up from county cricket
um to the test arena no one's making
that sort of adjustment very easily um
so i i don't know who they're going to
be stuart broad he's coming to the end
of his career would you pick him if he's
if he's actually now you know
potentially droppable
i i don't know is the is the answer i
don't know what they're going to do but
clearly joe root feels he's done as much
as he can yeah and it is not going well
so you know fresh eyes are needed jackie
for now thanks very much indeed